c'est la course contre la montre aux
entrepôts montréalais on doit charger
toute la marchandise qui sera acheminée
par le dernier bateau à partir avant
l'hiver dans l'es14 coopérative des 14
villages du nunavik comme un magasin
général de la nourriture les vêtements
des jouets de noël de le papier toilette
les gauches des meubles tout
l'ameublement c'est vraiment compliqué
mariottat pas d'autres cas la rhénane
lapierre a commencé à travailler à la
fédération
alors que c'était une toute petite
entreprise au début des années 70 jean
bleu et de ballades la culture aux
spoilers chasseurs pêcheurs
c'est par là que tout commence
sur les bords de la baie de son on en a
marre d'être exploité par la compagnie
du même nom
en 1967 le père peter stein accordé
cette entrevue à l'émission focus de la
sib ici à tout le groupe
j'ai rassemblé un groupe et je leur ai
dit ne seriez-vous pas intéressés avant
une compagnie bien à vous d'où au début
ils étaient surpris se débrouiller sans
les blancs je l'aï dis bien sûr vous
êtes capable de le faire
le gouvernement du québec nous a donné
18 mille dollars et on est parti comme
ça nous a cherchés à mouches est le
dernier survivant du groupe fondateur
l'homme est extrêmement fier avez vous
commencé devenu gros nous demande-t-il
et oui c'est gros plus de 300 millions $
de chiffre d'affaires par année près de
12 millions $ de retour on membres en
dividende
la fédération des coopératives qui
gérait au départ la vente de la
sculpture et de petits magasins généraux
oeuvre maintenant dans la
câblodistribution de pétrole
l'hôtellerie et le transport de cavage
arrêtent ou louga qui dirige la
coopérative depuis vernis touques nous
fait faire le tour du propriétaire
l'hôtel garage le restera les immeubles
loués par le gouvernement du québec
tout ou presque appartient désormais à
la coopérative belfort notre survie a
toujours dépendu de notre travail ardu
de se lever tôt chasser avec l'idée de
ramener de la viande c'est un peu le
même principe que dans les affaires
[Musique]
et h m est le mal est qu une vague
l'argent c'est les blancs qu'il faisait
avec nous c'est facile à comprendre nous
maintenant on fait de l'argent pour nous
pourrions plus qu un putsch celui qui a
vu naître ce mouvement de fierté
économique rêve encore plus grand nous
devons continuer à grandir pour nos
enfants dit cet humble sculpteur qui
aura rendu les inuits un peu maîtres
chez eux
émilie dubreuil radio canada puis vient
ni toc